PROFESSOR: So what I would like
you to do is to answer
the following question.
"Do you have..?" oh, now
wait a second -- this
says polling closed.
Let's see whether we can
get polling to open.
Do you...?" -No, that
didn't work.
Oh, this is the most desperately
horrible thing
that I've ever had happen.
OK.
Current slide.
I've had horrible things happen
that are worse than
this, I'm sorry.
I don't want to belittle all
the really horrible things
that have ever happened to me.
[laughter]
OK.
So let's try again.
Click practicalities
blah blah.
OK. "Do you have
a clicker yet?
Polling is open." OK.
And there's ten seconds left.
You'll see this little
timeline.
Eight, seven, six, five, four--
ninety two of you, so
many of you have clickers.
OK.
Let's see what we learned.
It looks like 97% of
you have clickers.
[laughter]
Now!
I actually began with this
exercise to make a point about
psychological research.
We just made a classic and
dangerous mistake, a mistake
known as sampling bias.
We used a measure which doesn't
give us accurate
information about what we
wanted to find out.
We wanted to find out, what
percentage of people in the
room had clickers.
And what we found out instead
was, what percentage of people
in the room with clickers
had clickers.
[laughter]
I don't know who you guys are.
This error is an incredibly
dangerous one, and it could
have persisted.
Suppose I then ask you a
question whether you're from
the class of 2014, '13, '12,
or '11, and discovered that
80% of you were freshmen
and sophomores.
There, then, I would inherited
exactly the sampling bias
error that we just observed.
Freshmen and sophomores
have handed in
their schedules already.
Consequently, they're
certain about what
classes they're taking.
Consequently, they're
more likely to
have clickers already.
So when we do psychological
empirical research, we need to
be extraordinarily careful that
the means by which we are
choosing subjects for
experiments are, in fact,
means that give us an accurate
sample of what it is that
we're interested in.
An article appeared recently in
the journal Behavioral and
Brain Sciences with the
title, "The Weirdest
People in the World".
And "WEIRD" here stands
for Western, educated,
industrialized, rich,
and democratic.
That is, American college
students.
People with access to online
Internet polling.
And what the article argued
was that a great deal of
psychological research that
claims to make general
assumptions, that claims to
prove general assumptions
about human nature, is biased
in exactly the way my poll
concerning what percentage of
you have clickers was biased.
It looks at a small sample of
the population, those who are
readily available to research
laboratories on university
campuses, for example, the psych
introductory psych pool.
And it bases its conclusions
about human
nature on that sample.
Throughout the semester we need
to be attentive, when we
read psychological studies which
are making claims about
human nature, to the fact that
it is possible that some of
the things which we are told
apply to human beings in
general instead have at least
being shown conclusively only
to apply to WEIRD folk.
Western, educated,
industrialized, rich, and
democratic.
And in certain cases, the data
would look very different if
we looked at a different
population.
This is also the case in the
classical texts we used.
The process that Plato and
Aristotle took on for
themselves didn't look
experimental in the way that
experimental psychology
looks experimental.
But they looked at a sample of
people around them, and on the
basis of their experience, they
drew conclusions about
human nature.
So little reminder of something
that I said in the
first lecture that sometimes
gets lost. In some ways, this
is a class about philosophy
and the
science of human nature.
And in other ways, this is a
class about Western philosophy
and the science of Western
human nature.
And we need to be attentive to
that when it becomes relevant.
So what I want to do in today's
lecture is to return
to the issue that we took up
last class, which is the issue
about the multi-part nature
of the human soul.
And you'll recall that in the
last lecture, we were
introduced to Plato's great
analogy of rational spirit and
appetite, as exemplified by a
charioteer, a calm horse and a
wild horse.
And also to a number of
other distinctions.
Left brain, right brain, which
I managed to get wrong four
times in a row, if I
remember correctly.
We were introduced to the
difference between brainstem
and upper brain.
We were briefly introduced
to Freud's idea of
superego, ego, and id.
But we didn't get to work in the
dual processing tradition.
And today's lecture will take up
where the last lecture left
off, with another way in which
it is typical to distinguish
parts of the soul.
Let me say that there is very
good reason to think that the
research which I'm presenting
today is not subject to the
WEIRD objection.
That is, there have been
powerful cross-cultural
demonstrations of nearly all
the results which I'll be
talking about today.
And there are also good
evolutionary reasons to think
that the two systems which dual
systems theorists posit
are, in fact, going to be part
of any human being because of
the evolutionary process, which
all of us underwent.
So I wanted to start with a
picture of Edward Thorndike
not because he's important,
but just because he's so
fabulous-looking.
This is from the New York
Public Library Archive.
Edward Thorndike was a late
19th, early 20th century
psychologist who did a lot of
important associationist
animal work.
But he also did research,
publishing an article in 1922,
that in some ways can be seen
as the founding work of the
reasoning tradition that
Jonathan Evans described in
the article that we read
for last class.
So he describes, in his 1922
article, an experiment that he
does, which is titled "The
Effect of Changed Data Upon
Reasoning".
And what he's interested in
there is the question of
whether problems that are
posed to people that are
formally identical, but that
differ in how that formal
material is presented, are
processed differently.
So, for example, he asked
people, either what is the
square of x plus y, (first,
outer, inner, last, I think is
how you would do it) and he
asked people, what is the
square of b1 plus b2?
Whereas people found the first
question easy, they found the
second question much
more difficult.
Success rates on this
were up around 90%.
Success rates on this were
considerably lower.
Or he asked them, what's the
square of a squared x cubed,
versus what's the square of
r subscript 1 to the 8th r
subscript 11 to the second?
And so on.
Presenting people with problems
that were formally
identical but which differed in
terms of the complexity of
the characters used to represent
them produced a
massive decrement
in performance.
Fast forward to a period in the
1960s, '70s, and '80s, in
which people began to study
syllogistic reasoning, and a
number of special instances
of this phenomenon emerge.
So in Jonathan Evans piece that
you read for last class,
you were presented with
examples like this.
A syllogism that was valid and
believable - that is, whose
formal properties guaranteed
that if the premises were
true, the conclusion was true,
and as a matter of fact
conclusion was true.
And arguments that were valid
but unbelievable--arguments
where the structure of the
argument guaranteed that if
the premises were true, the
conclusion was true, but where
the conclusion was false.
So, for example, you might
be told: No Greek
tragedies are comedies.
Some Greek comedies are plays.
And asked whether it followed
from that that some Greek
plays are not Greek tragedies.
No Greek tragedies are comedies,
some Greek plays are
comedies, therefore, some Greek
plays are not Greek
tragedies, and 90% of people
were able to see that that
argument was valid.
By contrast, you might be given
an argument, equally
valid, but with an unbelievable
conclusion; like:
No Russian novels are short.
Some novels by Dostoevsky
are short.
Therefore, some novels
by Dostoevsky
are not Russian novels.
That's a valid argument.
It's a valid argument with a
false conclusion, because one
of the premises is false.
But as a result of the
conclusion being implausible,
only 55% of people were able
to recognize that the
conclusion followed
from the premises.
Notice, however, that these
two arguments are
structurally identical.
They both have a form, no A's
are B's, some C's are B's,
therefore, some C's
are not A's.
Formal properties alone
don't determine our
ability to judge validity.
And, in fact, it is also true
that formal properties alone
don't determine our ability
to judge invalidity.
So whereas valid arguments with
plausible conclusions are
judged to be valid roughly 90%
of the time, we just heard
that valid arguments with
implausible conclusions are
judged to be valid considerably
less often.
An opposite error arises in the
case of invalid arguments.
Invalid arguments with plausible
conclusions are
judged to be valid.
It's judged to be the case that
the form of the argument
guarantees the truth
of the conclusion.
Whereas it turns out that what
guarantees the truth of the
conclusion, in that case, is
nothing other than facts about
the world, as opposed
to facts about the
structure of the argument.
In light of this Thorndikean
condition, researcher after
researcher came up with research
paradigms that
demonstrated what we've just
been talking about.
So, famously, the Wason
selection task asks people to
determine which of four cards
they need to turn over to
verify the truth
of a statement.
So, for example, I might give
you a statement, "if there's
an A on the one side, there's
a three on the other." And I
might present you with four
cards, and ask you which ones
you need to turn over.
Obviously, you need to turn
over the A, and everybody
recognizes that.
You need to check whether
there's a three
on the other side.
Obviously, you don't need to
turn over the D. You know that
the cards have a letter
on one side, and a
number on the other.
So there's no worry that
there's an A on the
other side of here.
But people have a tendency to
think that you need to turn
over the three, and that
you don't need to
turn over the seven.
But look out.
Right on that other side of the
seven was an A. and the
statement turns out
to be false.
The ones you need to check
are the A and the seven.
People find this task relatively
difficult.
But here's a structurally
identical task that people
find relatively easy.
"If a person is drinking beer,
the person must be over 21." I
show you four cards.
The beer drinker, the soda
drinker, the over-21 year old,
and the 17 year old.
And every single one of you
could I take it get a job as a
bouncer, walk in, discover
that the 17 year old is
drinking a beer.
And thereby, learn exactly
what was hard to see in
earlier case, that the cards you
need to turn over are the
first and the last, rather than
the first and the third.
Now, there have been all sorts
of explanations hypothesized
for why it is that we find the
second of these tasks easier
than the first. Perhaps the
most famous of these is a
hypothesis advanced by the
evolutionary psychologists
Leda Cosmides and John Tooby,
who argue that we have within
ourselves what they call a
cheater detection module, and
that we're enormously sensitive
to cases that
involve violations of
normative rules.
So you notice that the second
one is different from the
first in two ways.
One is that it's socially
embedded, whereas the first is
purely abstract.
And we'll discover, as we
continue our readings this
semester, that social embedding
awakens reasoning
processes that aren't
present otherwise.
In fact, we learned that last
week, with the eyes study when
we learned that people are more
pro-social, more likely
to engage in morally normative
behavior, when they're
presented visually, with eyes,
in part, because it awakens
and activates a kind of social
understanding which all of us
have.
So the first difference between
the bottom and the top
is that the bottom one invokes
sociality, whereas the top one
is purely abstract.
And the second difference
between the bottom and top is,
of course, that this is
a normative rule.
It's about how things
ought to be.
Whereas this is a descriptive
rule.
It's about how things are.
So the lesson that we can take
away from the Wason selection
task, for those of you who are
interested in it, there have
been thousands and thousands
of variations done on it,
which are extremely interesting
in sorting out
exactly where people are good
and not so good at the task.
The lesson that we can take
away from it is the lesson
that has been emphasized
throughout this lecture and
the previous one.
That we have ways of processing
information that
don't merely track formal
properties.
And some of those ways of
processing information involve
bringing on line, so to speak,
what Plato would call parts of
the soul which had not
been previously
attentive to the situation.
Now--
Is there a question
in the back?
STUDENT: Yeah, sorry.
For the last one, what exactly
were the subjects asked to do?
I don't really understand
the experimental design.
PROFESSOR: So the experimental
design for both of these cases
was as follows.
You're given a sentence
that you need to
verify the truth of.
So you're asked is it true that
if there's an a on one
side, there's a three
on the other?
Is it true that if a person is
drinking beer, the person must
be over 21?
And you're told that you have
four items in front of you,
and you're asked, which ones
do you need to turn over to
verify the statement?
So to verify the statement, if
there's an a on one side,
there's a three on the other
side, you need to turn over
the a and the seven, not
the a and the three.
And that should become obvious
to you if you look at this
case, where to determine
whether the person was
drinking beer, the person must
be over 21, you need to turn
over the card belonging to the
beer drinker, and the card
belonging to the person who
is in fact not over 21.
So does that clarify?
Excellent.
OK.
So dual processing accounts
attempt to provide a general
explanation for what's going
on in the cases I've just
described, and in the cases
I'm about to describe.
They suggest that we have two
relatively autonomous
mechanisms for processing
information, and they're
called all sorts of things,
but what's become the most
normative way of describing
them, is to call them simply
system one and system two.
So whereas system one is
evolutionarily primitive--it
makes use of parts of the
brain that came into our
evolutionary process relatively
early in the
game--system two is
evolutionarily relatively
recent, it involves higher
cortical function.
System one is unconscious, or
preconscious, whereas system
two is conscious.
System one operates
automatically, whereas system
two is consciously controlled.
System one is effortless, it
happens without our trying.
System two is effortful, in the
sense that it involves an
expenditure of cognitive
energy;
you have to pay attention.
System one is super fast. It
processes information almost
instantaneously.
System two is, relatively
speaking--
slow, the information that we
get through system two takes
considerably longer: seconds
rather than milliseconds.
System one is associative.
It recognizes patterns
in the world.
System two is rule-based.
It can apply principles.
System one is, people sometimes
say, reflexive --
it happens without reflection,
which is what
underlies system two.
So the distinction between
system one and system two is
the result of many decades
of work by many people.
Here's a chart from a different
paper by Jonathan
Evans in which he enumerates--
and this will be available
to you on the V2 site--
some of the many researchers
whose work went into talking
about system one
and system two.
And I want to point out to you
one important thing here,
which is that it's a bit
misleading to speak of system
one and system two as if they
are individual things.
System one is sometimes called
the autonomous set of
subsystems. The idea: there is
the visual processing, and the
auditory processing, and there's
processing that gives
us very specific information
about things like faces, or
the average length of lines,
or that enables us to
recognize something as
predator or prey.
All of those systems have
the characteristics
that system one does.
They're quick, they're
unconscious, they're
evolutionarily primitive,
they come online without
reflection.
But they are not, each of them,
they are not altogether
a coherent system.
So dual processing accounts are
a way of trying to make
sense of a set of phenomena,
some of which have to do with
the processing of reasoning,
and some of which, as we
learned in the absolutely lovely
Nobel Prize speech of
Daniel Kahneman, which I asked
you to watch for today, some
of which takes place in a more
general domain of reasoning.
And I've reproduced for you
here Kahneman's beautiful
chart explaining his
understanding of the relation
between system one
and system two.
Where he talks about the
similarities between
perception and intuition
on the one hand and
reasoning on the other.
And again, I'll leave this slide
for you on the website.
So what I want to do in the next
part of the lecture, is
to move from the discussion of
Evans, which in some ways was
left over from last lecture
though connected to this one,
and talk a little bit about the
work of Daniel Kahneman
and his collaborator,
Amos Tversky.
So you're now going
to get the second
chance to use your clickers.
We're only doing one other try
today, and if this one works,
we'll have a whole slew
next Tuesday.
OK, so this is the famous Asian
disease problem from
Kahneman and Tversky, and
it runs as follows.
A terrible disease has struck
600 people in your town.
Without treatment, they're
all doomed.
You are the mayor, and
there are two courses
of treatment available.
If your last name begins with
the letters A through L,
you're going to need to read the
information that I'm going
to put in the green box.
So with you head pointing over
to this side, and only read
what happens in the green box.
If your last name begins M
through Z, you're going to
read information in
the blue box.
And let me tell you, we will
use these color conventions
throughout, if this ends up
working, and that the A
through L group will have only
numbers '1' and '2' for yes
and no, and the M through Z
group is going to have numbers
'3' and '4' for yes and no.
So if you're an M through Z-er,
look at the blue, and
get your fingers ready on three
and four, and if you're
an A through L-er, look at the
green box and get your fingers
ready on one and two.
I asked Marvin Chun how to do
slides like this, and this was
his suggestion.
OK.
So ready?
I'm going to tell you about plan
A and plan B, so look at
your side of the board
and not the other.
OK?
So read about plan A. And now
read about plan B. OK.
Get your clickers out, and if
you are on the green team, use
'1' to indicate if you'd choose
plan A, and '2' to
indicate that you'd choose plan
B. And if you're on the
blue team, use '1' to indicate
that you choose plan A and '2'
to indicate that you
choose plan B. OK.
I'm going to put on the timer.
We want 64 to 66, zillions
and zillions
and zillions of responses.
And let's see how the
numbers come out.
OK.
Here are our numbers.
Those of you on the green team,
40% of you chose plan A.
Those of you on the blue team,
only 25% of you chose plan A.
Ah, you know what?
This is actually not --
So.
We--
The relevant size of the bar
is relevant but this is
divided into a 100.
I need to learn a
little bit more
about how to use clickers.
So let me now regroup and
make my point again.
As you'll notice, on the green
team, the relative preference
for plan A exceeded the relative
preference for plan
B. Whereas in the very small
second half of the class,
which consists of, the problem
is that 60% of you are in A
through L, and only 40%
of you are M through Z
(this is our problem).
OK.
But in this group, if I could
quickly do 26 times 0.4, we
would be able to find out
what that what absolute
percentage it was.
In this group, the relative
preference is for plan B
rather than plan A.
Notice, however, that plan A
and plan B are identical.
There's 600 people.
And under plan A, 200 people
will live; which means, 400
people will die.
And on this side, there are 600
people; if we go with plan
A, 400 people will die, which
means it's certain that 200
people will live.
However, the results which you
all showed are, in fact,
exactly the typical
set of results.
Typically, people presented with
a problem that involves a
choice between certainty and
probability framed in terms of
its positive outcomes will go
with the certain rather than
with risky plan.
Whereas people who, told the
same thing, where they're
given to focus on the certainty
that 400 people will
die tend to go with the
probabilistic option.
Notice, again, plan A and
plan B on the two sides
are exactly the same.
Just one is framed in terms of
who will live, the other in
terms of who will die.
And the result is almost a
complete inversion of people's
preferences.
And we get these sorts of
framing effects over and over.
Here's a study by Kahneman and
Tversky's student, Eldar
Shafir, from the early 1990s.
You go to an ice cream store,
and you're hoping to get
yourself two flavors
of ice cream.
One is a good flavor, the other
is an excellent flavor,
but it has high cholesterol.
And you discover that you only
have enough money to buy one
of the ice creams.
So if I asked you which one
would you choose, 28% of
people choose the good flavor,
and 72% of people choose the
excellent flavor with
high cholesterol.
But if I ask you which one do
you give up, 55% of the people
give up the one with the good
flavor, and 45% of the people
give up the one with excellent
flavor, high cholesterol.
So even though, in
this case, 28%--
even though these are exactly
the same question, which do
you choose?
If you choose A, you give up B.
If you choose B, you give
up A. These numbers
don't match up.
When you're asked which one
you choose, the excellent
looms large, and so you go for
it, neglecting the high
cholesterol.
When you're asked which one
you give up, the high
cholesterol looms larger.
This phenomenon occurs
over and over again.
Suppose you're going to a movie,
and when you get to the
theater, you discover that
you've lost something from
your wallet.
What you've lost from your
wallet is either a $10 bill or
a $10 movie ticket which
you had purchased last
night for the movie.
You get to the theater, you
open your wallet to go in,
either, in the first case, to
pull out a $10 bill to buy the
ticket, or in the second case,
to pull out your "Admit 1"
ticket to let yourself in, and
you discover that you've lost
the item that would have
enabled you to
get into the theater.
However, you have another $10
bill in your pocket, and the
question is: do you buy
another movie ticket?
For people who've lost a $10
bill on the way to the movie
theater, 90% of them say, "I
lost a $10 bill, but so what.
I'm going to buy a new ticket."
For people who have
lost a $10 movie ticket which
is of exactly the same value
as a $10 bill, only 42% said
that they would spend the $10
to buy another ticket.
So framing is one of the
examples of a heuristic, or
bias, which Kahneman
and Tversky
focus on in their work.
We will return to some other
examples later in the
semester, when we read the
work of Cass Sunstein.
What I want to point you to now
is a particular example,
which is going to serve as our
segue into the idea of alief.
And that's the distinction
between frequency and
probability.
So suppose you're trying to get
a red ball because getting
a red ball will help
you win a prize.
And you have a choice about
whether you want to draw from
this box over here, which has
nine white balls and one red
one, or this box over here,
which has eight red balls and
92 white ones.
So here you have a 10% chance,
here you have an 8% chance.
And you're going to be drawing
from the boxes blindfolded.
An image for which I don't
suggest doing Google search.
So, I found blindfolded
justice.
That did a little better.
All right.
So you have your choice.
Do you want to let this
box be the one --
you're trying to get a red ball,
-- do you want to let
this box be the one, or
do you want to let
this box be the one?
Obviously, rationally, you've
got a better chance over here.
But people are in fact pulled
in two directions.
You had a 10% chance over here,
but my goodness, there's
8 balls over here!
8 8!
1 8!
More!
What's going on here, I suggest,
is that whereas you
have a belief that here, you
have 10% chance, you have what
I call an alief that here there
are eight, whereas over
there, there is one.
So alief is a notion that I've
actually discussed on
bloggingheads.tv with
Paul Bloom.
And though we were filming in
different places, here I am in
the game room at my house with
our geo-puzzles, here's Paul
in the study, it appears that
we were separated at birth,
because that's at the same
time as that photo.
All right.
So suppose I take you to the
Grand Canyon, and I bring you
out on the glass walkway that
extends 4,000 feet above the
roaring river below.
And you step out there
with me, and you
voluntarily remain there.
I take it if you voluntarily
remain on a glass surface
4,000 feet above a roaring
river, you believe that
surface is safe.
Nonetheless, I will wager that
most of you would shudder and
shiver and shake.
And you'd do so because you
have what I would call an
alief that says to you, "I am
4,000 feet in the air, with
nothing holding me here, and
I'm going to tremble."
Or suppose we're watching a
Western movie -- anybody
recognize that gentleman
who was president
when you were born?
When you watch a movie, a
Western movie, and the bullets
are flying off the stage,
obviously you believe that
you're safe.
You don't think, "oh, what a
good thing it was that the
bullets didn't come off
the screen this time".
Nonetheless, particularly
in 3D, you will
bend your head down.
If the green slime is coming off
the screen, you'll tremble
in your seat.
If Anna Karenina is about
to die, you will cry.
Not because you believe that
you're in danger, but because
you have an alief.
How many of you set your watch
five minutes fast, and then
subtract back down?
When you do it, you believe
that it's ten
but you have an alief--
you look down at it --
10:05!
It enters your visual system ,
it gets processed really fast
and it says "10:05!
Hurry!"
Or suppose you're watching a
rerun of your favorite team on
television, and you know that if
one of the guys on the team
tries to steal second, he's
going to be thrown out.
And so you yell at the
television screen, "Don't run!
Don't run!" Why?
Because you believe that your
voice is going to go through
the television screen, back in
time, to first base to reach
the runner?
No.
You have a belief that it's a
rerun, and your alief says
"don't run".
Suppose you're on a diet, and
you see this beautiful piece
of chocolate cake and you have
the belief that it's
undesirable.
Your alief system, in the form
of your Platonic horse may
nonetheless pull
you towards it.
Suppose I present you with this
delicious cake, those are
Tootsie rolls, this is a
perfectly clean and sterilized
pan, that's coconut there, in
fact, this one has the same
ingredients as that
one, exactly.
You believe me, right?
I'm your professor, you're
here, listening
to what I tell you.
I tell you, this is edible!
Tootsie rolls, coconut.
Nonetheless, I take
it that your alief
system kicks into gear.
Suppose I ask you to sign this
contract: "I hereby assert
that my soul belongs only
to you, O Satan".
And I write at the bottom, "This
is not a legal contract.
It's just a prompt in a
psychology experiment." You
will, nonetheless, be reluctant
to sign, not because
you don't believe that this is
a legal contract, right?
[high-piched voice]
"Oh my goodness, if I sign my
soul over to the devil, I can
tell it's the devil--it's
parchment." No.
You believe that there's
nothing to it, but
nonetheless, you hesitate.
Suppose I take you to Monica
Bonvicini's bathroom, which
is, as you can see, completely
opaque from the outside.
You stand outside this public
restroom, you peer into it,
you see that there's no
way to see inside.
You belief is that you are
totally protected.
Nonetheless, when you go in
to use the facilities,
it looks like that.
And your alief makes it rather
difficult to do what you had
gone in with the intention
of doing.
Suppose we have a bag of sugar
and two glasses of water.
And you take a spoonful of the
sugar, and you put one in this
glass and label it "Sugar,"
and one in this glass and
label it "Poison." You took the
sugar, you put it in the
glasses, you put the
labels on it.
Nonetheless, people
are reluctant to
drink from this glass.
Moreover, they're not just
reluctant to drink from it
when it says poison.
They're reluctant to drink from
it when they've written
the words Not Poison on it.
Why?
Because the word poison
is there.
Running into your
alief system.
Good sugar.
Mmm drink sugar.
Poison?
Don't drink the poison!
--OK.
Suppose that I have a kitchen,
and I'm interested in making
some kitty litter cake,
so I have my cake
pans stored over here.
And a chef comes in and says to
me, it would be much more
efficient if the cake pan
were over on the right.
He's very pleased with
what he's done.
And when I ask him to get the
cake pan, he says, "I'm so
happy that we moved the
muffin tin cake
to the right cabinet".
And those two get it, believing
it could be on the
right, exactly where
it used to be.
His belief is that it's
on the right.
His alief is a lagging habit.
Any of you who has ever
rearranged your room knows
this feeling.
Any of you who has ever put your
cell phone in your hand,
and then looked for
your cell phone--
I've had terrors of having lost
my children, and then
realized they were
on my shoulder.
So to have an alief is roughly
to have a representationally
mediated propensity to respond
to an apparent stimulus in a
particular way.
Right?
So the apparent stimulus of
the glass staircase, the
apparent stimulus of the kitty
litter cake, you have a
propensity, that's either
innate, as in the case of the
glass, or the fudge shaped
like feces, or a habitual
propensity, as when you
arrange the kitchen.
These are habitual ways of
responding to the world that
activate the sort of lower-level
systems that we've
been talking about.
And importantly--although we
can recognize alief most
easily by looking at these kinds
of discordant cases, the
cases where belief tells you
to do one thing, and alief
tells you to do the other.
In fact, alief is active
all the time.
Every time I've used my right
thumb to push the key on this,
I've done it out of alief.
Fortunately, it's one that
corresponds with what I intend
to do, but it is certainly
the case that an enormous
proportion of our actions
are governed by alief.
The question is this.
Given that I just showed you
that there are hundreds and
hundreds of ways of describing
what I adverted to with the
notion of alief, why introduce
this new term?
The story has something to
do with alief itself.
So every 20 years or so, the
United States government
introduces a dollar coin.
Here's the one they introduced
in 1921.
in 1972.
Here's the one they introduced
later in the 1980s.
in 1980,
with Susan B. Anthony.
Here's the Sacajawea one they
introduced in 2003, and in a
massive fit of public relations
genius, here's the
Millard Fillmore golden coin,
which will be issued soon.
What's going on here?
What's going on here is that
it's hard to get people to
make use of something if it
doesn't fit into the currency
system which they
have already.
Dollar coins don't fit naturally
into the ways that
Americans use money.
Likewise, talk of system one,
system two, relatively
autonomous systems, heuristics
biases and so on, don't fit
naturally into the way
that we have of
talking about ourselves.
We talk about ourselves in terms
of beliefs and desires.
And in order to make use of
the gold coin that is the
recognition of the multipartite
soul, we need a
notion that fits into our
conceptual currency.
And that's the role that my
hope is alief will play.
So alief is going to return
to us in later lectures.
We'll hear about it again in the
context of the harmony of
the soul and in other domains,
we'll hear about heuristic and
biases and we'll hear about
the multipart soul.
I look forward to seeing all of
you on Tuesday for harmony
and happiness.